[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture est tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 31
mai du 2 au 4 juin phénomène et
compagnie investit la grande écurie du
roi avec amphitryon une oeuvre peu
connue de molière c'est la création 2010
est du mois molière qui débute le 1er
juin à versailles et les
clayes-sous-bois ont aussi leur festival
c'est les talents clés siens et ça met
en avant les associations de la commune
et percy weasley et l'un des grands
frères de rondo ron pardon il était à là
il était à versailles ou plutôt son
interprète chris rankin
l'acteur était présent le week-end
dernier pour une séance de dédicaces
cette année c'est la 22e édition du mois
molière le festival versailles et débute
dès ce jeudi 1er juin un mois de
représentations de musique de danse de
cirque et de théâtre
parmi les spectacles à découvrir une
oeuvre peu connue du dramaturge français
amphitryon cette création est faite par
stéphanie tesson et phénomène et
compagnie pour le mois molière 2017
reportage sosie vallée est chargé par
amphitryon de prévenir son épouse de son
succès mais il est remplacé par mercure
qui prend ses traits au fit riom est une
comédie en trois actes de molière je
trouve que c'est la pièce la plus folle
de molière
plus pour moi la plus mystérieuse la
plus peut-être intime aussi celle dans
laquelle il a mis des choses
certainement les plus profondes et plus
secrète de lui c'est louis nous confie
son rapport au ciel à l'au-delà à tout
ce qui n'est pas humain on connaît le
molière humains humaniste mais là on
découvre un molière habité par une fois
c'est moi qui suis senti dans une pièce
sur la symétrie sur la gémellité une
mise en scène épurée où la ressemblance
est à voir dans l'ain du jeu des
comédiens
elle suppose évidemment des acteurs
extraordinaires que j'ai la chance
d'avoir autour de moi des interprètes
d'une grande puissance intérieure parce
que la ressemblance n'est pas forcément
uniquement physique elle est aussi dans
les sentiments
c'est une pièce sur la vérité pour moi
in où est la vérité sur un plateau de
théâtre c'est l'acteur et le plateau nu
cette espèce de façon très très pur et
très simple très humble de porter le
texte comme simplement un ambassadeur de
ce texte qui est quand même un
chef-d'oeuvre absolu elle les dix
comédiens font vivre cette oeuvre du
dramaturge français écrites en 1668 une
oeuvre peu connue du grand public dans
un écrin de choix la grande écurie du
roi 3 statuettes obtenus sur les cinq
possibles pour des co productions du
théâtre montansier de versailles hier
soir lundi 29 mai c'était la cérémonie
des molières les césars du théâtre la
première récompense est celle du
meilleur seul en scène pour emmanuel
noble et avec réparer les vivent les
femmes savantes
elle mise en scène par catherine hiégel
sont repartis avec deux statuettes celle
du meilleur comédien pour jean pierre
bacri et celle du meilleur second rôle
pour evelyne buyle on écoute geneviève
dichamp quand directrice du théâtre
montansier c'est vraiment mérité parce
que c'est trois très belles prestations
et très belle interprétation de comédien
jean-pierre bacri qui était vraiment
magnifique
en ce rôle du père dans les femmes
savantes et bling ou une bulle
absolument exceptionnel de finesse et de
qualité et puis donc ce projet des
manades mauvais qu'il a quand même
adaptée mise en scène et jouée ce n'est
pas toujours facile de on va dire de
porter l'entièreté d'un projet l'amour
tragique la jalousie amoureuse et nobel
bohémienne la recette de l'un des opéras
les plus célèbres de georges bizet créée
en 1875 les clés lyrique groupes
amateurs des clayes-sous-bois a choisi
de l'interpréter cette année il faut
l'ouverture du festival talents clés
cyan le 2 juin
regardez carmen la femme fatale
une femme fière et sensuelle oeuvres
majeures de georges bizet l'une des plus
jouées au monde choisi par les clés
virer le fait que ce soit un opéra qui
est extrêmement culte c'est vraiment le
genre d'opéra que les amateurs pas les
experts c'est à dire qu'ils voient la
dette c'est vraiment pour tout le monde
c'est un peu comme une opérette ça
ferait un peu plus sérieux ça touche à
des choses plus profondes et les
morceaux sont absolument splendide
caro ensuite lui sur scène une vingtaine
d'amateurs une année de travail pour
raconter les amours tumultueuses de john
josé carmen
[Musique]
j'ai cerné le personnage de carmen et
les dodgers et c'est extraordinaire et
le plus con on
plus qu'on creuse dans ses oeuvres le
plus qu'on peut trouver c'est qu'à moi
quelque chose qui est un peu son fin on
dit que c'est le premier femmes libres
dans l'histoire de l'opéra libre de son
esprit libre dans son corps elle c'est
ça qui est gêné horriblement 2h15 de
spectacles pour plonger dans le cv du
début du 19e siècle et découvrir
d'autres titres de ce célèbre opéra
[Musique]
le festival des dates des talents clés
siens à dur lui jusqu'au 6 juillet du
théâtre de la danse et du cinéma seront
aussi à découvrir pendant un mois les
talents de la ville sont à l'honneur
christelle bidoire cantina trice de
l'événement nous en dit un peu plus elle
était au micro de camille lambert et à
beaucoup de choses on a dix associations
de représenter certaines ont deux dates
on a quatre établissements scolaires
aussi et deux établissements
hospitaliers donc c'est vraiment très
une programmation très étoffé c'est un
moment de lien social aussi entre
l'espace noiret les associations les
différents publics
l'idée est vraiment de répondre au fait
que l'espace noir est un centre
socioculturel donc à un besoin social où
on peut se rencontrer et faire une
spectatrice en sont un autre rendez-vous
de cinéma ne pas manquer qui s'adresse
aux amateurs de cinéma le samedi 3 juin
c'est la sixième édition du festival du
court métrage cette année 18 films sont
en compétition un jury de professionnels
rendra son verdict et un prix du public
est organisée on passe maintenant au
coup de coeur cinéma
[Musique]
le coup de coeur de la semaine c'est
celui de gaël paineau le responsable du
grenier à ciel à celle de trappes
on les écoute cette semaine j'ai très
envie de vous parler de notre coup de
coeur depuis 1999
le cinéma le grenier à sel travail avec
le lycée de la plaine 2 nov la trappe
pour les pour accompagner les élèves
dans la création de films de cinéma et
donc les élèves du lycée l'appel
d'offres est une option cinéma qui
présente au bac cette année vendredi de
juin à 18h30
nous allons donc présenter des films qui
ont été tournés cette année dans les
seconde première terminale
l'entrée est libre c'est une cérémonie à
laquelle il y aura un jury nous aurons
aussi évidemment un prix pour le film
que le jury aura sélectionné le prix
sera double le prix ce sera le la
projection en première partie d'un film
professionnel au mois de septembre donc
un film d'actualité et ce sera aussi la
remise de
du film en format cinéma que nous aurons
condé en format cinéma pour qu'ils
puissent être proposés dans les
festivals
ce sera vendredi de juin à 18h30 le
l'entrée est libre
n'hésitez pas à venir pour trouver ces
informations sur notre site internet
cinéma grenier à sel points comme à
bientôt pour les fans d'harry potter le
27 mai c'était une journée spéciale à
versailles l'art war geek recevait percy
weasley le grand frère de ron ou plutôt
chris rankin son interprète de nombreux
apprentis sorciers avait fait le
déplacement
preuve que la pottermania n'est pas
terminée six ans après la sortie du
dernier film un sujet d'haussmann van
der des et de nicolas d'andré cathy
soulès cyclistes à loxam access persie
wesley le frère de ron dans harry potter
que de souvenirs l'acteur chris rankin
était à l'armoire geek pour une séance
de dédicaces un moment privilégié que
les fans de la première heure ont saisi
ça m'a fait plaisir c'est vraiment
j'avais la larme à l'oeil tellement dans
le film bel ami j'aime trop il est
vraiment bien il était décontractée
c'était très bizarre c'était la première
fois que je voyais un acteur qu'on
reconnaît dans la rue en fête est un
acteur de harry potter et il a été très
gentil
c'était un peu stressant mais c'étaient
ses découle un moment unique pour les
aficionados ainsi que pour l'acteur qui
ne connaissait pas versailles pour chris
rankin rencontrer des fans est toujours
un grand moment
onesphore âme s est dit heureux c'est
merveilleux c'est étrange et que ça lui
survivra longtemps je veux dire ça fait
dix-sept enfin saison que le premier
film est sorti ça fait toujours bizarre
que les gens viennent me voir je peux
comprendre pourquoi ils veulent
rencontrer percy weasley c'est important
pour les fans d'harry potter mais c'est
toujours c'est toujours étrange c'est
adorable l'amour qu'il nous donne car
harry potter signifie beaucoup
après la séance de dédicaces plusieurs
activités ont été mises en place pour
les fans dont un jeu de piste avec une
carte du maraudeur de versailles
avant de nous quitter quelques rendez
vous à ne pas manquer un rendez-vous de
jazz pour commencer avec les flashs pig
le collectif créé en 2008 proulx
participe au premier happy hour de juin
du prisme à elancourt regardez cet
extrait
[Musique]
bon
toujours au prisme le 7 juin l'équipe
vous présentera sa programmation pour la
saison 2017-2018
la soirée sera placée sous le signe de
l'originalité de la surprise le metteur
en scène pierre notes et ses comédiens
ont carte blanche une exposition dernier
rendez-vous celle proposée par 150
écoles des yvelines à la commanderie des
templiers le résultat d'un défi
technologique que leur a lancé l'atelier
des sciences et l'éducation nationale
les élèves ont dû confectionner des
objets sonores et vous pourrez les
tester à partir du 7 juin de 7,8 culture
est maintenant terminée je vous remercie
de nous avoir suivis et vous dit à
mercredi prochain
[Musique]